what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're gonna watch and or
episode 10 today but before going into
that we got a sponsor I am so excited to
be working with so today's video sponsor
I'll admit we did not really know much
about them when they first approached us
and we've been a little bit more
selective about who we choose to partner
up with yeah with this but this is
actually a perfect fit and I wish we
knew about them sooner because what they
have to offer is awesome something that
we'll definitely be using and something
I think you guys really enjoy as well
and that is fan home now what fan home
is is a subscription-based service that
makes unique Collectibles and build up
models based on some of your favorite
fandoms such as Star Wars Marvel Street
Fighter you know what fandoms are and
yeah each bottle is broken down into
different stages and they're sent to you
in installments so you can break up the
process over time and what's cool is
each one comes with a collectible
magazine that has the next set of
building instructions along with trivia
and facts about the show posters and
whatnot and I was particularly excited
because the model they decided to start
our collection with is kit from Knight
Rider which is one of the most classic
TV cars of all time and you know I grew
up with Knight Rider my dad actually
worked on the show back in the day so
kit and Michael Knight and all that
stuff has been a part of my life since I
was we I was pretty dazzled by the level
of detail they put into this you know
lights turn on the doors open it all
kind of works and I cannot wait to build
it and display it and then share that
with my Dad yeah hopefully you finally
get that approval you've been looking
that's right this is the time this is
the this is it so to get your own kit
yeah I love the ways it sounds it's
double okay let's get your own kit along
with some awesome free gifts hit up our
special link in the description box and
use the code promo real r-e-e-l like
real rejects get it promo real start
your fan home subscription today and get
building and pressure John to submit a
photo when he's done building
foreign
ended up back on two the next day but
what happened to three well if you
subtract two from four
there's two still exist and what's on
four then if we turn six upside down
would that put us on level nine
it has to be tomorrow they don't have
enough guards and they know it
they're afraid right now they're afraid
they're so fat and stupid so fat and
frightened a power doesn't panic five
thousand men are about to find out
they're never living here alive whatever
we're making here is clearly something
they need if they're building the Death
Star
from program every day we wait they get
stronger and fatter you don't have time
to be stupid come on
it's around a new man coming down I'd
rather die
take them down then die giving them what
they want
to die yeah
but Andor is now officially a rebel yeah
it's true it has to be tomorrow
[Laughter]
[Music]
circus is so good I know what a treasure
what's going on with these ships
it's gonna be a prison riot try to smoke
what
they will rally if you say something
quiet you heard him say this
I don't believe it oh my God he is
falling apart no one is getting out
true oh great music we're gonna die here
or in the next place
level five
start figuring this out
Oh Captain My Captain
[Music]
oh you don't look like you slept a wink
and door we are done
with counting shifts
there is only one way out I'm gonna
assume I'm already dead there's no sense
in mourning the night shift can't wait
to talk about his performance in this
episode
let's make it look good
God I got shot got chills right now
[Music]
sakino just feels betrayed in a way you
know like I did my time I did my duty I
was honorable about my sentence and they
didn't even tell me it wasn't the game I
was playing this entire time yeah I just
left chandrilla and my boss at the time
thought I'd enjoy seeing it has it
changed much
I can't tell
didn't pay enough attention what a thug
that was golden he's a thug searching
for a more fluid banking situation are
we
yes
we're exploring alternative financing
arrangements for our foundation
look how real the environment Coruscant
feels my feet we assume it's a
percentage of funds transferred I want
nothing money means very little to me at
this point uh
I insist and I refuse some kind of
Leverage though a drop of discomfort may
be the price of doing business
oh
that's good I'd like to come back here
at least once I'm sure that's something
that can be arranged I have a 14 year
old son and I'd like to bring him with
me
and marry him to your daughter you can't
be serious A daughter's 13 she'll soon
come of age
two young people attractive and
privileged and drilling citizens turning
in the house of the track
our two strong houses would be even
stronger is that your only offer
I'm afraid So Tay will see you out
what if it's what your daughter wants
you don't listen to her mind off my
daughter wants to date the son of a bad
boy
people in power don't panic
oh come on you need a vacation
you barely like your daughter
who cares what happens to her
I'm just messing around it's been a year
I'm surprised he waited this long
then if it's a trap
well if it's a trap we've already lost
there's a crap
we really do
shaking hand don't care I'm dead I'm
dead you're dead anyway I would love it
if all them die except and or
we were ready for this
come on come on Kino you deserve your
day in the Sun
this new prisoner's lucky day yeah all
right
come on
here we go
this is like what's happening at my
house
okay
this is every time I use the toilet
[ __ ] is so much wetter than when I came
in
oh Jesus
[Music]
let's go on full prison shank let's go
yes let's go
why are you so sweaty son
foreign
[Laughter]
oh geez
would you say to me I said nothing I
mean if you want to say something you
should say it now
yes
oh my God it's happening
what's going on out there go go
oh my dude
[Music]
just take it out with that guy it's your
unlucky day yes new guy oh dude
oh new guy new guy we barely knew you we
barely knew the new guy
oh nice shot that's right you guys gotta
oh my God
damn it
come on Andy
guys you guys are terrible shots
[Music]
all right get on the tables everyone get
on the tables everyone get on the tables
whoa oh wow
ah
all right well that worked
oh hell yeah
oops
Caesar's back
if you throw it get out of Dodge right
wait don't wait to see if it lands yeah
oh bam there you go and door you're
already a better shot than both of those
guys
wow
we'll kill this guy yeah yes
double tap two man they're leading the
Rebellion
oh snap
too bad for the upper levels
oh my God they're all getting guns
lots of guns okay boom
it's a jail break you know stay alive
I'm not sure so we just
I've got Service warnings on every panel
get over there
this is the floor with the Asian guys
yeah
it's a segregated prison even down to
the guards
sucker One Way Out come on fly
what what are you talking about they
might not be aware of level two
yeah
dang
nice
guy what if some of these guys are
actually bad you know yeah I mean it
stands to reason for a couple of them
this is a facility-wide emergency
announcement complete program protocol
will commence in 40 seconds what you
could have done is snag some sneakers
and or excuse me turn it off that could
mean so many things
I'll turn it off
I don't have it
he has the hydrogens
wow wow
put more money in the show than Obi-Wan
Kenobi it really feels like
the physical sets the CG effects geez
get out of them
shoot him in the ass
both cheeks one program all yours how
you like it
tell him what to do come on bud you do
this every day tell them what to do
my name is
I'm speaking to you
from the command center on level eight
we are at this moment in control of the
facility yikes
is that the best you got
they can hear you in
how long we hang on
how far we get
how many of us make it out all of that
is now
up to us all the flaws
hope get out of yourselves take charge
and start climbing
they don't
have enough gods and they know it
they're going to start putting on
prisoner uniforms getting out of here we
will never have a better chance than
this I would rather die try
to take them down and giving them what
they want we know
fried a hundred men I'm level two stupid
fat Hobbits it's a fat greedy
but when they say we are being released
we are being transferred to some other
prison to go and die and that
ends today that's right ah these shots
man you see someone who's confused
someone who's lost
you get them moving and you keep them
moving until we put this place behind us
what a speech
oh the doctor believes yeah that's
probably also now thinking of all the
many could have saved I want to release
handicap those guys shoot them in the
knees or something
[Music]
or tied them up yeah
oh guys guys wow
they're terrified damn dude
oh nope someone fell
oh people are voluntarily jumping
no
[Music]
no
cops win
no no
someone better catch him someone better
float a door his way
oh wow
they are all Tim Robbins
[Laughter]
I understood that right
wait what's happening with keto I know
Blade Runner
[Music]
what are you up to this is a trap press
the buttons for 215.
it was pretty years since we've had a
chance to catch up you'll become a
father
it's not worth mentioning
well do you have to think how it might
feel from my side I think about you
constantly
searching for
a thief and the middle man
nothing to do with aldani well almost
nothing we were invited but declined
[Laughter]
this can't be why you're here
oh interesting we know that there's a
raid planned on the power station at
spellhouse if Krieger attacks they'll be
waiting and if he doesn't they'll know
something to miss they'll be slaughtered
it's 50 men
you're worth more than that woof better
way to reassure the ISB there's no leak
in security that's sacrificing Krieger
wow
this is a very disorienting elevator run
yeah oh
I took my wig off for you I can't do
this anymore we talk about I've been
working my way through there for six
years working my way up
alone
so what was your plan looks almost Sith
like yeah we've been grooming you for
too long and yes you've been alone
your career has profited greatly from
information that we're provided
information that cost me daily
you're trapped Lonnie
it's no pleasure in saying it but you're
going nowhere
[ __ ] something else cold your
investment in the Rebellion is epic the
stress of that
we need Heroes Lonnie and here you are
so freaking epic bro what do you
sacrifice
sleep
calm behind us kinship
love I've given up all chance at inner
peace I made my mind a sunless face oh I
wake up every day to an equation I wrote
15 years ago for which there's only one
conclusion
I'm damned for what I do
I anger my ego my unwillingness to yield
my my eagerness to fight that set me on
a path for which there's no Escape
respect what is my what is my sacrifice
I'm condemned to use the tools of my
enemy yeah I burned my life
to make a sunrise that I know I'll Never
See
now the ego that started this fight will
never have a mirror or an audience or
the light of credit
what do I sacrifice
everything
yeah so get back to work you get to have
a kid at least
you'll stay with me Lolly
I need all the heroes I can get that
Lutheran writes some great goth poetry
though dude this is just the monologue
episode I know and the people they got
to deliver them jeez
wow that must be freezing
[Music]
those moons
cool what happened to Kino
he's not dead we didn't see it he's not
dead
Kino lives
Justice for Kino Justice
for Kino
wow that was an episode that was it did
stuff then it's like an episode and a
half
all right let's talk about it
alrighty well yeah I thought that was a
really um
good Star Wars that was good cinema of
anything yeah James Cameron doesn't know
what he's talking yeah screw James
Cameron talking [ __ ] on Star Wars
nowadays yeah you guys hear him do that
oh man Quentin Tarantino and uh they're
all just directors for hire that's Star
Wars that's right man well he said he
would do a Marvel in DC but never a Star
Wars well yeah not after they
single-handedly try to hold him down
with hateful eight you know that's true
that's right
um this was this was a great episode
this was really awesome this is a tour
of force yeah I thought it was rooting
rousing I found myself just on edge I
just felt like a jolt of like oh my God
I'm nervous oh it's gonna happen yeah
breathless the whole time I mean it's
just such a great build like we've only
been here for what three episodes in
this prison it's only been here for
three episodes
it feels like we've been here the whole
season
in a good way not on like Jesus get this
plot over with this feels like in
eternity no it's really well fleshed out
in each episode not like they don't ever
spin their wheels and what they give you
over the course of that three episodes
or four episodes yeah it was like Kino's
character Arc yeah you know the whole
time it's crazy the transformation that
he went through from his introduction of
oh my God Andy Circus is like the
villain of the prison
the guy who's he he he almost I would
sort of
I don't know why this is the first I'm
sure there's a much better comparison
than this
but for some reason the one that first
came to mind when uh his character was
first introduced was Samuel Jackson and
Django Unchained okay you know yeah yeah
like come on they're the bad guys
you are clearly even though you have
some sort of power position this is
clearly only like a abided by them and
you are not actually going to benefit
truly from this situation they are
enslaving you you guys I mean granted
the goal of motivation was very
different that he would have his chance
of Freedom not like he wanted to rise
the ranks and stay there forever yeah
like it's not the same in his vocation
not the same thing nor is the slavery
comparison 100 accurate here
um
even though it's a form of of but come
on we know one is a very sci-fi prison
in general do I need to explain the
details for you guys you should be smart
enough to know
um but yeah the the that character of
like he doesn't come across to me like
in the beginning that he's gonna be
a
a protagonist really uh or maybe not the
main antagonist but he really seemed
like he would be someone who would just
be an opposition in some way and you
watch as the the truth becomes unveiled
to him and his performance in this
episode it was just the absolute
highlight because he he's here for three
episodes and it feels like he really
built like a whole history of this
character like we don't really know
where he comes from before this prison
we don't really know much about him all
we know is he's got a goal to get out of
there and he's got to serve his time and
he's almost there so he runs a good
system in place to make sure he can meet
his time requirements
and you're watching him just slowly like
oh my God this is not what I was
promised everything I work towards I'll
never have a shot at Freedom again and
it seemed like he knew that there was no
way out that
no what I mean that is the most literal
sense of
he can't swim like you know there was
something about it where it wasn't like
oh my God
I came this far no it's like he knew
where they were
and because of course of course he knew
they were they were all dropped off
there but he knew that I have no shot at
getting out of here yeah no matter what
I choose yeah I'm not leaving here so
he's he's doing this for them at this
point like he found a bigger cause than
just them and it was also uh it's like a
hybrid of for the people there and then
also Vengeance towards what they did
yeah you know and it's it's a great
performance I thought it was a very very
powerful performance and
you know it's like you're even
when he got to that speech it was the
final moment of there is even though
he's gone this far with attacking and
rebelling and writing back
in that speech you're watching like once
he puts his voice to this microphone
there's no going back yeah whatsoever
Yeah it's you're fully taking charge of
the situation right now even if you do
have and or kind of over there
encouraging you through it yeah yeah
you're you are making this a true uh
Rebellion with an actual or at least you
know within the confines of the prison
you're you're making this an official
coup and I like how they've
fleshed out and or because it's called
and or it's his show but in some ways
he's like Mad Max you know what I mean
yeah it's a good way to put that he's
someone who
stumbles into these situations
apocalypse and then it's usually
involving uplifting someone else you
know yeah yeah yeah I'm just here to do
my job and and get through I can't do
that I guess I'm just gonna have to help
you guys make a better situation out of
a terrible one yeah yeah and he's kind
of a scoundrel rough and tough so I I
thought it was a really great episode
and you're watching as yeah the
Rebellion go this is how I've always
imagined Pokemon could do the human
world
Pokemon just decided why are we fighting
each other for these humans yeah putting
our lives on the line almost meaning
death every minute of the day waiting to
be Unleashed from a Pokeball most humans
carry around several of us really we if
we just work together they would realize
these humans are outnumbered and we
could dominate the world yeah
so these prisoners were like Pokemon
at each level was the Pokeball
collectively ready to go and that and
Andy Circus who would be a great Mewtwo
by the way
yeah totally would be a fantastic voice
for mutant come on there's no denying
let's go back and start that trend of
re-dubbing old anime movies with new and
improved voice guys I think live action
CGI that's right do a mocap okay perfect
yeah Mewtwo he would be a perfect mutant
and then he can also show up and play
like Professor Oak just so that we also
give Andy Circus his on-screen chops I
feel like so many play Sandy circus
shows up as uh you know a CGI mocap
character they then also need to go we
need to give him like an actual on
screen role so people recognize that you
know Andy Circus is a great actor and
not just the mocap guy
sure he was snoke that's right he was
just no gorgeous and now Star Wars snow
Wars the fact that he
didn't jump off that ship and if we
don't find out what happened
a little more Credence to the theory
that this is somehow oh he was the the
leader we could use his DNA yeah look at
how yeah no they saw it they were that
Andor was mistaken they have been
watching and they saw the leadership
potential in this guy and this ax only
just proves it more so they come in they
pick him up they're like we need more of
this in the Empire coming with us jump
in this tube here yeah you know there we
go snoke Origins it's pretty much
already like most of it is set up by
this so snoke Origins will be like in
the next few episodes probably
uh yeah that's uh it was wonderfully
Illustrated and inspiring and uh you
know I it's really easy to look at it
and go well they got to be criminals
right and some of them got to be just
criminals it's a prison and then you
forget
you gotta remind yourself like well this
is
this is the Empire's prison
yeah yeah yeah so these people probably
do anything that bad yeah they're bad
anything bad at all well there's
probably some overlap in the in the Venn
diagram of deplorables yet you have to
imagine like the people the Empire are
locking up are probably not just the
biggest scum of the Galaxy sadly I mean
and or is a prime example he was locked
up there for for chilling for sexism
that's right if you're sexist uh-huh he
was he was locked up for uh misusing
someone's pronouns yeah yeah I could
care less about his race
or profiling him based off of the way he
looked and came across yeah uh that was
that was awesome and I I really admire
I just like admire the scene work you
know like in scenes you usually have to
have
an arc percine in some way you know
there's there's all kinds of models I've
heard of before you know the the most
common one that I would hear
if is is like if it starts negative it
has to end positive and then the next
scene has to start positive and then a
negative I don't really agree that it
has to go that direction but I do think
there should be some type of trajectory
you know in it and I think the scene
with Lutheran and
mustache man
well I'm trying to find his name here it
is Genevieve O'Reilly that's that's him
Mustachio what is that character's name
I heard of the bunch didn't we I feel
like Lars I just don't want to pause I
don't want to take a second to slow down
the conversation it's okay I can pull
him up I mean I could just play it or I
could just find it right here here we go
yeah there's Kino there's the voice of
God the voice of God that's a great
gulaf God credit good for him for being
dead they must have actually used him
that's great to hear Saul is it is it
supervisor legret Lonnie it's Lonnie
Lonnie
he's uh yeah a supervisor young yes yes
Lonnie Lonnie young
um yeah great
he was I mean I think that's what they
do so well is is in viewing these
characters of such Rich history much
like the Pokemon who deserves definitely
this is one to one
um just give Dave filoni and and John
Farrow Pokemon and Tony Gilroy too no
you're turning Gilroy I'm really
interested in the Pokemon really care
about Pokemon I just want to tell my
story of animals rebelling against their
cockfighter torturers yeah uh
Lonnie uh because in in that scene you
know the the way they the way they paint
Lutheran
it does come across like Lutheran's a
villain you know you're in you lock into
Lonnie's perspective when he's taking
the Tower or Terror elevator right it's
just a terrifying elevator ride
um seriously I mean we shouldn't they
they have like some of the best
technology there's no reason there's no
excuse for any elevator I feel like
Lutheran specifically chose that
elevator right that elevator just for
the sole purpose of
effect like fear I bought this abandoned
space and I'm going to set up my
meetings here which is the scariest
possible place to be I wouldn't be
surprised if he just tinkered with that
elevator himself yeah just to just to
provide that yeah
it's ridiculous that elevator right yes
um that's just not safety who's taking
that elevator up and down yeah what is
this elevator's actual purpose during
the daytime this is terrifying yeah yeah
they got to fix that thing how do you
guys get such a good calm link between
the no but he's so like he he holds such
a power and he's so threatening
um over over Lonnie the entire time and
Lonnie's just kind of desperate and
pleading and like he the way he presents
himself like Lonnie's part of the
freaking Empire right like that's the
disguise he's been such a snivel so I'm
confident when I'm here but then when
he's with Lutheran he's like afraid he's
gonna get killed which is such the
antithesis to when you think of one of
the leaders of the Rebellion one of the
main instruments
so in that scene you know the way they
capture Lutheran is like oh this guy's
going to the dark side or some [ __ ] you
know like he just seems so dark and it's
a fascinating portrayal of a man who and
I thought the way they they they uh
deconstructed that to Showcase that oh
yeah no Lutheran's right because at
first you're like damn Lonnie you're
right this guy's terrifying yeah I'm
like oh [ __ ] yeah Luther now really has
given up like everything hasn't he and
he's he's had to
quote-unquote play by their game and by
that it's it's be ruthless and be and
and make these dark calculated choices
with in a normal soulless way
when it's for the cause of good it's
like this it's like so ironic and
anybody's giving up everything to to be
that guy like and it it is a it's a
painful speech but man like man respect
Luther absolutely and I think that uh
theme I think it was really nice the way
this episode complemented those two
monologues especially because everything
with Kino like it is the fight uh I mean
again we didn't see him die so he might
not have died but it is that fight that
Lutheran later on talks about of for you
know fighting for the sunrise you'll
never get to see or to you know create
those circumstances and right and yeah
like the show has already done so much
to show you that yeah this business of
the Rebellion while hope is a big part
of it it is dirty work and his whole
spiel about having to be being accepting
that you're doomed to work in the the
tones and use the tools of your enemy
and just what that does to your soul
like it it goes to show and you know
none of us has lived a violent Rebellion
but yeah like in order to enact that
kind of change and make that well then
you can you can corroborate everything
I'm about to say and correct me if I'm
wrong
um I thought I accidentally dropped my
pokeballs oh no and I thought they had
gotten out due to my own negligence
that I know my threatening Pokemon
mm-hmm
Butterfree oh the worst slow poke oh not
a slow poke no don't speak its name
maybe Snorlax ah caterpillar
not a Togepi too Togepi
they had all gotten loose wow that
sounds like Mayhem massive Rebellion
they wanted out I did find them and was
able to put them back in the Box put
them back out of place where there's
like 10 minutes but it felt like a
lifetime yeah yeah that's good and I
hope they know never to step out of line
again for fear of your intense wrath
yeah but that was like a rebellion it
was and you could and you called it you
know you you re-established order with
an iron grip yeah I almost said Iron
Fist
um but yeah like in the in the crafting
of a rebellion it seems like one thing
that this does well to acknowledge and I
think complements the original movies is
like we spend most of the time with the
original Star Wars movies with people
who will get to enjoy The Spoils of the
fight who will get to have some kind of
connection to the outcome that is
Equitable for everyone whereas yeah at
these early stages and especially with a
character like Lutheran you're like oh
yeah you really do have to just be re
resigned but also incredibly driven by
uh yeah the knowledge that what you're
doing is is right and and you have to
have that like ultimate foresight of
like this is what we're building and
this is what it's going to cost and
without people like that none of these
would probably happen and so you get
yeah like the the Luth inside which is
this sort of long gestating operation uh
you know and even just watching is he
has to deal with the chess game of
information as Lonnie's riding up the
elevator him being like yeah you know I
guess we're just gonna have to uh
sacrifice our player here and I guess
you're just gonna have to feed them more
of this information and you know it
would look weirder if uh you know we did
avert the tech like it is cold and there
is an element where yeah I guess you
would have to become desensitized and
it's it's a fascinating portrait of
something like this because I think is
absolutely intentional that he's like
standing there and the black cape is
flapping in the ominous like I don't
know how there's wind here but it just
must be the Winds of sinister poor tents
um yeah it's like it borrows for a guy
who purportedly doesn't care that much
about like Star Wars iconography like it
uses that stuff really well and even
Lonnie is like
I loved the guy's performance and I mean
I've seen him each episode he's appeared
in and thought like guys well cast for
one of these snively you know supervisor
Imperial types but like the amount of
presence and and and nuance and sort of
heartbreaking pathos that he had in
those moments was really
really lovely in a sad way you know I
think we need a tone down this talk
about Tony Gilroy like not liking Star
Wars I'm sure it's blown away out of
proportion I think it's blown I don't
think he would have signed up for 24
episodes if he did not for two seasons
like Star Wars first off yeah and maybe
he's not a fan of the way Star Wars has
sort of played out with
you know the the turning out the
Jedi [ __ ] always Nostalgia into that
Skywalker I get it all right like I can
understand that maybe he didn't even
like the prequels okay
but the fact of the matter is
he and it rarely says that he is the
writer of the episode and I don't recall
when it says I don't even know if he's
directed an episode
he's directed a couple but he has it was
Tony
Toby Haynes has done a bunch of them
okay African Doctor Who and then I think
did Dan I think maybe it doesn't matter
anyway okay even if he has direct he
hasn't directed most most of them and my
point with that is I'm sure he's not
there with the other writers and the
other directors and when they want to do
something for Star Wars he's not he's
like
no never no I hate Star Wars we are
doing the opposite it's not The Witcher
writer's room okay don't honor Star Wars
at all he's got a whole I'm treating
like yeah everything like gather a bunch
of people who were like yeah [ __ ]
story
we did it we won we infiltrated the
Empire now we're gonna Rebel with good
storytelling yeah it's uh I I I think we
need to like tone it down this is this
is too well developed and too fine-tuned
to have been made by somebody who is
coming at this from a place of disdain I
don't see one thing here on IMDb that he
directed any of the episodes John I'm
then maybe it was Dan Gilroy
maybe maybe Dan director said that was
such assured confidence well I remember
then he definitely wrote the first
couple or or something but that's my
point is like they keep saying like it's
as if this is his baby that has he has
his yes he's the creative head oh [ __ ] I
don't think they're good
put this to the tester hold on a second
who's the one who writes who directs me
says Toby hate Toby hands yeah okay I'm
gonna type in Toby Haynes on IMDb
and yeah he's credited for episodes that
he's directed Toby Haynes
I don't see them Gilroy Brothers being
credited must be I must be a Star Wars
hater myself just saying that sounds to
me like you I hate Star Wars yeah I hate
Star Wars do I I hate uh so much I don't
pay attention to who directs her writes
any of these things don't ask me who
directed Empire and Return of the Jedi
do you know because I always forget
Lawrence Kasdan
that's a
a good guess maybe
I know one of them is a name I probably
wouldn't pull I think right there's one
there's one that's this is a great well
I'm pretty sure I think the story goes
that he that George pretty much directed
them
Irvin kirschner there you go Laurence
Chasm be on the scripts I I'm pretty I'm
pretty sure the story is like yeah he's
pretty much directed it you know like
yeah George Luke is pretty much directed
it uh
and yeah I want to say Ross Marquan
directed uh
definitely but I'm pretty sure it wasn't
him and then Andy Circus uh directed
Empire Strikes Richard marqueline
all right dang you are doing much better
at the time than I am not far off there
no I'm really proud of myself for coming
close to guessing the director
and then who we got on on Empire Irvin
Kirsten Irvin kirschner again oh no that
was again we just did sorry yeah it was
Lucas and then these two yeah George
Lucas directed a new home sorry an
attack of the Clones
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's why Tony Gilroy hates Star Wars
that's right as a matter of fact he made
me Tony Gilroy has convinced me to hate
the original trilogy it's all terrible
yeah I hate what they've done I hate
everything except for Andor and and
whatever he did on Rogue one
uh I believe he kind of directed it too
right yeah I mean that's the word on the
street is brought in to retool it
um maybe yeah no this is a great episode
and uh Deidre is looking fine yeah all
right that's the main takeaway yeah and
uh you know mon mothma's kids gonna get
fired up yeah
yeah
poor her and her money and her lying to
him for the first time she lied she
shouldn't have been on guard from the
very first second I think that's a
really bitter in the ass negotiation
process yeah especially with a guy like
that who probably you know is only going
to become more and more sus of someone
who's on their guard look you know
sometimes I criticize when I hear oh my
God this 16 year old is in a
relationship with like a 21 year old
and then come to find out that oh wow in
New Jersey
um you know the it's the terms yeah the
the age of consent is like 16 years old
sorry 16. I don't know what the age of
consent is it's important Star Wars
World apparently it's like 14. maybe
because I'm just saying like I just
slept with this kid
dude just been like that
is the alliance you know keep it within
one of your boundaries that you have
between you and your awesome husband and
then just yeah get with that guy's kid
do you think they're having a great
physical intimate relationship
I'm sure mon mothimo would love
to Bob has been lonely
mama needs some sugar she does the
reason why she's putting all her energy
into changing his whole entire system if
she could just get some once in a while
she would be much more chill
so much yeah this should be like this
Palpatine's not that bad it is the most
sterile on-screen relationship who
fought back the hardest a bunch of
prisoners a bunch of prisoners a bunch
of male prisoners who haven't had action
that's right so that's right a show
about sexual repression yeah if all the
women in the Galaxy just decided not to
put out for anybody then everyone would
get every man would fight back that's
right and I'll go after that Vader guys
would all get their [ __ ] together yeah
go topple the Empire and then we're good
um yeah that was a great episode great
episode great acting great capturing
during any circuses monologues I kept
just thinking like how cool must he feel
watching this pack
uh Andy sergeis doesn't watch his
homework then I'm feeling it on his
behalf won't be on that and put me on
that 100 I know this for a fact I
believe research so much I believe you
just like not to making [ __ ] up that is
a hundred percent the reality that's why
Tony Gilroy hates Star Wars because he
just doesn't like watching his own work
no he doesn't realize how good it is
that he's making it back it's too bad
the other thing that was gratifying is
[ __ ] out crap
Star Wars and then he's he doesn't
realize how good it is what he's doing
you should crap more stuff out it's
pretty good when you do that he was
trying to ruin it but I made it better
so yeah this is like the producers you
try to sabotage and it just gets bigger
and bigger but uh no it was also nice to
have a Stellan you know stellen
Skarsgard like he's he's got that status
now where he shows up in a lot of stuff
and he brings his thing with him and you
know that's cool and all uh respect but
also watch he brings his watch and
everybody knows what time it is on set
but uh he's this was one of those scenes
where I was like oh yeah though he's
like a really great actor and that
monologue was like really gripping and
rousing and you know intense in a way
where I was like cool like I've enjoyed
him across this series and in the
various things he pops up in
these days but you know like it's nice
to be reminded once in a while like oh
yeah like you know you can throw down a
full-on performance you know I got a
great plot twist in mind for him oh he's
an artificial intelligence
oh that makes sense can you imagine that
that would be fun that would be
interesting he's played by Alan Tudyk
secretly
and then he becomes k2so
and then never mentions anything about
this during the events of Rogue one
skip thinking like an alien Blade Runner
oh that'd be cool and then he's like
crying in the rain at the end yeah who's
that bad guy he's right he's uh what's
Rucker Howard's name yeah you know that
character's name
yeah he's Rucker Hower he is
and he lives already and like you know
Stars guard in dune yeah he is he's the
yeah he's the bad guy he's the bad guy
that had hearken in Israel yeah and uh
and yeah getting Guff from people for
how he says the name all right
if there's specifics about how you're
supposed to say like harkonin but he
says harkinen or something well they
play some like Marlon Brando and
apocalypse now anyways he does play him
like a guy who could give a shitless
about anything you know it's just this
Big Blob of like I don't care as long as
you understand me
yeah
he doesn't know what he's saying no he
doesn't
yeah this is all just a hilarious
misunderstanding he's just talking and
not listening to himself and thus all
the problems in Dune arise all right
guys well what'd you think about this
episode did you cry leave your thoughts
down below still sounds for the patreon
Gene Jeter Gene Fred you've been up
loyal ass follow us for so long 49
months four years and a month thank you
so much for being here for this long
John did you just have a video go up
that uh
Community page yeah I believe it was a
cool try on haul a try on Hall of who at
the beach of of his friendo Nelson
Chavez oh my God ornlc I'm not sure I'm
pretty sure
absolutely
stunning yeah and she is trying on
something in this video she's trying out
like a scarf thing oh a different scarf
thing a bikini swimwear thing I own that
exact same bikini I do I own the yeah I
own them both I Mean Gene it's great
that you're able to
get these people on camera for you're
able to coerce people into your Tech
videos commentary that I make here today
definitely you inspire us to try more
things including different swimwear at
the beach yeah um I just want to say uh
yeah let's try on haul videos it's a
great video and uh
every Gene Jeter video is a great I can
Admire from afar and a respectful manner
with many repeat viewings yeah
because I'm interested in the clothing
and in fact thinking of purchasing for
many loved ones honestly if that's why I
watch it a lot you could just do a try
on haul where it's just the clothing
that's even better
I don't need like a person in the frame
distracting from the clothes themselves
you know
yes I agree with this yeah that's what
my heart wants to say but but while we
are here I guess we'll make do with the
fact that you have you know such such um
you know cool yes wonderful
collaborators on screen with you
even though that's not she is gorgeous
she's gorgeous
it's not fidget how do you know so many
Beautiful People Gene what's your secret
oh that's easy
Bank of America Bank of America
hang out by the ATM excuse me
online banking it's online banking Bank
Bank of America is only online
no it's um there's an ATM okay I was
gonna say yeah come over and meet my
friend Andrew Jackson
that's a 20. for those of you playing
along at home yes all right guys well
guys subscribe to Gene Jeter TV Bank of
America Bank of America
buy some bikinis today
[Music]